今天应该是25年最后一天 然后我们正式的all look一下2026年会怎么样
就是这个风险资产
其实我今天想讲的几个问题就是26年的宏观
宏观上面有没有雷
然后宏观的大致的方向是怎么样
这是我个人看法怎么样
然后第二个就是对于AI产业和半导体产业
在这个产业里面哪一些资产 我们认为是在26年里面
我认为是ranking比较高的
因为我一直在说
就是我其实对于风险资产的投资
我可能在一年半以前就讲过几个票
这个单票的话
其实没有做过一个优劣的分析
然后其实也没怎么换过
我看它现在没有怎么特别的换过
这个声音稍微关一下
然后没有怎么换过
所以我就想把26年的投资
就是从个股的方面来看
我做一个排序
就是风险和收益的偏好
然后第三就是
今天我很少讲这些内容
就是第三的话
我觉得就是一个仓位
在现在的这个试点上
结合我们26年的all look
那么仓位的分布和
战术性的投资
你会怎么去做
我觉得这也一样
有些人可能像我一样
就是非常长期的投资人
他的做法可能和
比较active的投资人不太一样
我这边说比较active的投资人
因为我有比较active的常委
也有比较长期的常委
我就说一下我比较积极的常委
那么怎么样去做一个调整
然后主要讲这三个问题吧
然后这个就是
因为今天讲到的
涉及到个股和投资的选择
那这个可能自己自己斟酌
因为每个人风险偏好
或者是每个人对于
不同半导体的理解都不太一样
然后这是景光参考
然后首先我说一个26年的all look
26年就是我这边一句话
概括就是那个风险资产
我认为是往上的一个趋势
这个事情我讲过很多
但是是一个非常
是一个颠簸的路往上
那为什么中间会颠簸呢
因为市场分歧很大
就是我当我讲几个
就特别是在讲到行业的时候
我会讲几个
就是市场现在非常割裂
分裂的一些看法
但是总之来说
现在市场对于AI
能够带动
能不能带动生产力
其实华尔街和硅谷的看法
是比较不一样的
就是华尔街的帮人
其实否认了一个点
就是他们并不把数字生产力
当生产力
就认为AI
其实中间就有很多泡沫
然后中间也有很多过多投资
所以就是因为有预期差
然后AI并没有那么大的需求
这个是本质的
就是大家觉得AI
没有那么大需求
所以这些投资有点过度
投资刚才率太高
所以我们现在有风险
这个是华尔街很大的一个认知
就他们那边的东部的认知
然后西部有一个认知
就是现在那个投资没有泡沫
然后我们对于Token的需求太大
就Token的需求太大
以至于Bloodline现在投资没有泡沫
现在投资出来的Token的供应
在未来两年三年里面
都是有长期的缺货
那个两边有一个共识
就是26年要缺货
26年半导体要缺货
26年Token要缺货
但是对于后面的缺货
是不是会一直缺下去
那华尔街和那个硅谷
有很大的分析
所以你会看到在资本市场上
它有很大分析
当你的收益和你的所有的
很多的产出
要放在27年28年出来的
这些公司
比方说Oracle
然后Oracle 27年
就是你的那个
现在投的data散散
可能27年才有产出的
大家把你做空
然后认为你要破产
你那个过度投资
有风险
那CDS打上去
然后对于明年立马缺货
那我立马缺货
立马干
你就把那个存储和光谋块
给人炒下去
所以这个市场的分析是很大的
那你说华尔街他有信仰吗
他对于那个泡沫有没有信仰
他对泡沫有没有信仰
他觉得有泡沫
他要更一把
在短期里面他更一把
他只是对于长期没有看好
所以这个是市场
很分析的一个点
我们叫做AI
AI device
然后这个AI的分析
会导致明年有很多的
不确定性
就是他有很多那个商场下
我们叫Bumpirol
就是他有他有很多的那个
不确定
但是呢
我是偏向于相信
我是
我说出来的
但是我偏向于偏向于相信
规果
所以我是对于
中长期是非常看好
特别是你就看了不长远的话
看到明年底是非常看好
所以呢
在这个环境里面
就是你如果是一个
当然我们在讲头寸怎么去分布
然后
会对于你短期操作和长期操作
有不同的这个
有不同的操作方法
那么
除了AI的大分析以外
就是这个是AI的投资
投资的可能性
和那个大家
投肯需求的这个
投肯需求
确实不足的这个分析
然后
第二个呢
其实
大的形式市场关注
几个
一个是关注那个就业
和增长
第二个呢是关注inflation
然后隐身出来呢
就是大家关注美联储的政策
然后关注国家会放多少钱
其实我说几个
第一个就是
美国经济的增长不会太差
这个有很多方面原因
最大的两个就是
就是我们叫做
那个financial condition
就是那个
这个市场上流动性
还有就是国家花钱
这两个不太会停
所以呢
经济增长本身
其实我们上周
已经看到了GDP
这个当然
这一期的一些数据呢
包括CPR的数据呢
大家会觉得
稍微有那么一点
特别是CPR
大家会觉得有那么一些水分
这个网上讨论很多了
我这不退出了
但是
GDP的数据
4.3
超过预期
大家会觉得就是
三季多的数据
出来以后
觉得经济增长是
到底是怎么样
这接下去会不会掉了
那么我是觉得
就是说
经济增长有
三个两个推动力
第一个是政策产品
就是不管是
连储会变得比较宽松
然后连储会给银行松绑
还是政府会花钱
Physical stimulus
第二个呢
其实
我们今年看到了
大量的AIAG的应用
其实看到了
大量的公司开始adopt
我上早上说过
OBAI大规模进行
B的业务
它特别业务
已经做到六个别里了
然后
美国基本上
它没有花多少BD
然后把大量的美国公司
全部onboard
其实
AI在企业端
SARS端
在编程各方面
它对于整个生产
效率的提升
已经慢慢的
我看得出来
所以你说
经济增长在效率提升
在流动性变得比较宽
然后
政府在花钱的情况下
本身经济
会被
一线因素
就比较说
当时的关税
或者一线因素影响
会往下跑
但是它
全年的增长
不会太特别差
这个是
2026年的一个基调
就是
虽然我们在一季度
和二季度
有可能会看到
去年
特朗普政策所导致的
经济的短暂的下滑
但是
全年来看
经济增长是比较
我们叫steady的
比较稳定的
不会特别差
然后
为什么我把
经济增长和employment
分开
其实employment
比
这个应该是一一相关的
就失业率
就是经济增长怎么样
但是
失业的就是
工作的情况
其实不
又相对来说
又会比较
我们叫
高低LOCK的话
就是正好的
有那么一点点软
有点点弱
那这中间
也跟AI相关
就是AI
带动了
有一些人的
失业
包括你会看到
现在软件工程
失业就是挺多的
就是
编程的可能不太需要
那这个过程里面
就产业在更新
换代的过程里面
美国的失业率
我不会觉得特别特别低
就是
不会觉得它
能够
能够下去特别多
所以这个就决定了
美联储政策
就是比较宽缩
就是reason financial condition
这个
我觉得就是
哪怕它对于
通胀在短期里面
有那么一点担心
但是
它的那个政策层面
给银行松绑
短期里面提供流动性
这个我之前讲过
连处整体是会偏割的
那这个
我们去看一个
五年期的国债利率
或者十年期国债利率
这个中间
红颜色线就是国债利率
你会看到
如果说
大家真的对连处的政策
非常非常不决定
你觉得你不知道
割还是
还是硬的话
它不太会这样
这样穩定
其实大家
就是债券市场上
三号呢
大家还是
就总之呢
大家还是觉得
连处政策的确定性
不管
连处主席是谁
连处政策确定性还是有
就我之前讲的
叫做火车已经离战了
train has left the station
火车已经离战了
连处的政策
明年基本上激掉定下来
就是偏松
然后
财政政策也偏松
那么
主要的
在宏观层面的制约就是
inflation
那我对26年的通胀的理解
是26年的通胀下行
26年通胀下行
因为我看不到任何上行的
上行的那个压力
你可以看到
其实有很多的包括
通胀最难压住的那些
其实是那个
工资螺旋上升了
那你工资的成本的
leading就是
which survey
就是那个工资的
这个一些
leading indicator
就全部指向于
至少在工资的层面
就是
都是在往下
所以你说
今年能够把通胀
拉在一个相对来说
比较高的位置
中间很大的贡献是
关税
但是关税的影响
是一次性的
那到了明年
一季度以后的关税的影响
就因为去年
是四季度
开始加的嘛
那你后面的那个关税的影响
其实并没有那么大
或者你加了关税以后
你最多也就是
如果你加关税
你比方说我给这个杯子加关税
加了10%
那我这个
相当于这个factor的影响
10%
但是明年不会再加10%
它不是持续影响
所以关税的影响
对于PCE的持续的影响
它就是要下来
但是工资
包括AI提升效率
包括中国大量的出口通缩
所以我们看
美国通胀
就看这三个嘛
就是AI有没有提供效率
然后关税有没有持续再加
然后第三个就是
中国是不是继续通缩
中国会继续通缩的
中国通缩的情况还是比较严重
那个房地产我觉得没有走到点
那个中国的整体的杠杆率太高
然后那个人口
相当于是人口老龄化
杠杆率太高
然后那个房地产整个规模很大
区框杆不可能在
这一年里面走得完
你看中国现在大规模在硬浅
但是CPI还是上不去
就是你把中国想成一个
切尔多贝利的核电站
它现在不停地在
去掉那个control
希望把那个核电站功率给它提上来
它提不上来
它因为以前已经被整个杠杆给毒化了
所以它需要把这些杠杆都烧掉以后
它会发生一次爆炸
但是在这个之前
对美国的影响就是通缩
它输出的通缩
中国输出通缩
相当于人民币的carriage
出来的东西是产品而已
所以你想
这三个因素
都没有让你能够看到inflation
美国明年就是一个失业率
有那么一点点不好
然后通胀再走低
经济增长相对来说比较稳定
这个是指向一个牛市
就红官上指向牛市的
但是这个牛市中间会有分歧
因为毕竟
你这么说就比较说
我看英伟大的估值
是历史以来最低了
现在的话历史以来最低
它估值特别低
英伟大
但是在华尔街可能
这是个5万亿的公司
哇 这个是好大的一个泡沫
所以像这种分歧
会让市场就持续的来来
会不会有调整
但是这个调整的互动
我觉得不太会是
今年4月份这种
一次性的很大调整
因为没有红官的巨大的highway
但是红官的风险
就是你真的是说风险
它也是有
就是比较说政策怎么样
比较民运中期大选
会不会再搞一次
类似黑名贵的事件出来
这个都不太好说
但是如果仅仅看
经济的伙伴的话
从通胀来看
从增长来看
从employment看
从连处和国家的政策来看
都相对来说
比较还算比较好
因为你看
financial condition
就是那个流动性的
大概支持0.2%
Global growth
0.2%
这其实挺大的
几天
然后美国
日本
欧洲
欧元区
然后还有中国
我觉得中国没有力量去
这是高盛的
但是基本上
financial condition的support
2%
然后你看
这个是财政的
赤字
财政赤字
你把英国抛开的话
你就看欧门区
财政的影响
重复到整在一级度
然后美国的话
就前面两个
美国和美国
欧洲和中国
这三墙
中国其实从25年开始
一直在开始疯狂的花钱
美国花钱在四级度
但是问题是
四级度的影响
有政府官们
然后四级度的影响本身
这个东西的影响
也要lacking才会产生的
就是对于
经济的影响本身
要lacking才会产生
就是说
我确实
竞影响是真的
但是我后面的影响
可能一段时间才会产生产生
而且第二个就是
比方说中国
它在2026年
我们预期一级度
会花很多钱
那个对GDP的影响
可能是0.4的水平
这就拼命的在用
硬钱在用
但是
三级度
四级度你预期变少
它只是没有公布
它后面还有可能会继续影响
它这里硬了
没效果它就继续影响
就跟七两多倍力一样
它把那个
核电站的插锵给拔掉
它觉得功率还是上不去
它就拔更多
所以
还有持续的
新增的政策
所以你会看到
26年
这个在财政上面
美国 中国 欧洲
都是偏真
financial肯定选择都是真
所以宏观上
就是指向的是一个牛市
这个是比较清晰的
那么我们讲一下
话说
我们讲一下具体行业
我又没有想到
我想 正好
这个假期里面
稍微有点生
然后我说一下行业
因为行业里面的
大家会看到
最近吵得比较多的是storage
是存储
我从存储开始说吧
存储这个东西
缺货现在确实非常严重
而且其实比大家往传的
更加严重一点
就是美光
比方说我最近得到的消息是
美光把手机的排产
都放到了数据中心去
因为你要知道
包括storage
包括CPU其实都一样
它们的毛利率
在数据中心上的
数据中心的毛利率
是要高于消费电子
跟SWIMMATronic
包括车 包括手机
因为很简单
比方说英伟达的
比方说
级英伟达伟利
这不太恰当
因为手机上不怎么
地牢上也用GPU
英伟达的卡
300万 一个MV72 LINK
它在那个里面
一张卡的占的比率
成本比率是很低的
也就是说
它比方说
它在电脑上
它占的成本比率是很高的
手机一样的
就说手机你能够
一张卡能够忍受的成本
再上升50%和100%
你这个非常难
因为你从N3到N2
以后可能
继续用更加现金的现成
它的成本是
翻倍的增加的
那个成本翻倍增加的时候
其实我们未来面临的一个
面临一个大趋势
就是我们的芯片理顶
就是零领芯片
最先进芯片支撑的公司
从端到云
这个是很确定一个过程
那为什么
因为端能够付出的成本
就越来越低
你手机是没办法翻倍的
但是你的芯片
在MV72 LINK里面
可能就占了5%
我具体算算一个
4百块钱的卡
你去切200片
但是MV72 LINK
你想它一卖300万
你说原料成本
卡的GPU的原料成本
就是没有那么高
对吧
中间有各种各样的毛利
它所有的零配件
全部加了那么多毛利给你
所以
因为它是能够忍受更高的
就是它因为它产一个
最终解决方案
所以它不要说
比AMD
可能同期竞争的表说
做那个GPU的
它比那个
苹果以后都能够支付
更高的这个
流片的费用
也就是说现在
还有个趋势
就是你会看到
整体的芯片行业
从Wafer
从那个
Wafer到AP的变化
就是原来的效率提升
都是Wafer N3, N5, N3, N2
这样的提升
那么现在
台积电去做了个装
把那个效率提升
就放到AP
Advanced Packaging上面
所以最终
谁能够赚钱
就是我们先说这个GPU这样
或者是GPU这个算力这边
谁能够拿到算力
最后决定权
一定是在于谁能得到
拿到Packaging
对吧 拿到AP
那么
Intel的这些Packaging
肯定是在GPU上不能用的
它可能能够帮
可能能帮TPAs
不能用一下
但是主要是GPU不能用
那最后看到Advanced Packaging
那你的疯祸
在谁手上
谁就能够赚钱
为什么呢
因为整个东西的这个大伙计
是产多少卖多少
就是市场相不相信
能够按照产量
然后来定价
现在华尔街是不相信
就是觉得我不能按产量
你们产能过上
但是
但是它很分裂
它对于Storage又是
进行产量定价的
就是对于那个存储
又是产量定价
因为觉得存储是缺货的
然后GPU不是这样定价
那么这个分析在哪里
大家觉得
在短期里面
Storage缺了很多
但是GPU
它不确定就是
英伟达能够展胜出
还是谷歌的TPU能胜出
他们认为TPU
好像性能比英伟达好一点
然后是不是以后TPU胜出
TPU胜出还是英伟达胜出
都要用Storage
把Storage给炒下去
但其实并不是这样
因为现在Token的需求
实在太大
不管Token的需求大
带动了包括存储的需求大
带动了以后
后面会有的CPU的需求大
就整个产业全部会取货
不是TPU赢还是Nabilia还是GPU赢
而是他们都赢
他们两个都会赢
所以你说整个市场
现在最大的预期差在哪里
我们就说
你投半导体产业的话
中间会不会有一些固执过高
我告诉你
后面全部固执过高
这个光博块和存储
存储不好讲
但光博块肯定是固执过高
那固执过高不代表他不会找
他还会继续找
光博块肯定还会继续找
但是他固执过高
就是这个行业里面
为什么我们说光博块固执过高
因为光博块预期已经没有预期差
大家都知道他明年按照产能来
缺货按照产能来配货
然后存储差不多也这样
但是存储就是缺货缺多少
大家可能还不大知道
所以按照这个来配货的情况下
其实前端的CPU
GPU我个人感觉
预期差是最大
因为大家还在分辨是
英伟达COP还是TPUCOP
但实际的情况是
如果说Token的需求没有那么大
就是华尔街是对的
那么整条产业链全要垮掉
包括后面的光博块
包括Storage全不要垮掉
就模一形成
英伟达
如果你觉得英伟达是不行的这个票
那你也不要去炒3DX
3DX至少跌到70%
就MU至少跌一半
就你要如果觉得英伟达是
长期要跌到120以下
100以下这个位置
那就是存储这些要跌一半
LIT至少跌200以下
跌到100以下
就是AOID的10万钱以下
这个就是大家认为
最后没有这个需求
那个结果是传承了
人怎么能活下来
全部要死
但是我个人感觉是不会成
这个不会成
但是那么这种不会成的情况下
预期差就是在GPU
在CPU
投资是左边大于右边的
现在的估值是右边大于左边的
是这么过去的
那么这个就讲到半导体
中间一个很重要的
就是一个炒货的逻辑
炒货逻辑是缺货的时候
先涨价
然后补产能
补了产能以后
炒下一个缺货
那什么意思呢
就是比方说存储
你要知道存储和CPU
存储光博化和CPU
都是一对一嘛
也就是说你表说
你在Amazon上面去买存储个条
你不可能不配CPU
你不可能不配那个处理器的
所有的数据读取
它一定是CPU
它不可能是GPU
现在华尔街很多人
只是一个概念
觉得GPU代替CPU
这是没有可能性的
因为现在看到了AI Agent
就是比方说
OpenAI做的Mate Training
就是它包括它训练金融行业
其他行业训练医疗
它其实相当于
它自己在做一个Agent
然后市场上有很多人
现在真的出来做Agent
做了Agent之后
你就会知道
有多大的存储的需求
我朋友跟我举个例子
我这边举给你忙
就是举个例子
比方说我原来协产吧
是把所有人喜欢用的酒店
然后我在我旁边酒店
然后全部给你一些信息
upload到网上
然后用网上以后
所有人去调用
它需要的存储不大的
大家调用相当于是一个存储
我把这个东西
那个数据做好
然后放下来
但是AI不是这样
AI是我过来
我读取了我这个人
现在在香港的信息
然后我把旁边酒店的信息
和数据帮我生成了一个东西
然后把这东西存在这个网上
然后旁边比方说
James过来
那James在
我再尖啥嘴
James比方说在腕仔
然后他就帮你腕仔
又生成了一个数据
又存在那里
每个人都存一下数据
这个真的AIAgent
起来之后
你们对于这个数据存储的
需求是天亮的
恐怖
非常恐怖
天亮级别的
所以这个存储炒的时候过程是
现在CPU配的存储还没用完
那么大家知道
需要用大量存储的时候
那么这些人
就去把存储条全买完
存储条买完以后
先把它装进去
装进去完了以后
最后存储的量真的起
真的起亮了
他们扩产了之后
你会发觉CPU有不够用
因为存储必须是配CPU的
就我比方说我做一个Agent
我做一个假设TempusAI
我做一个药物研究的Agent
那药物研究的Agent
它所有的GPU的应用
都是API去调用的
我用API去调用OpenAI的这个系统
它并不是每个人
都自己在做春年
做春年什么几家公司
然后它调用了API
API一定是
GPU这个东西是规模效应
需要集群的
它一定是
用用英伟达的MV LINK
用这个卡做的
但是分布式的存储
就像说我刚刚说
我生成帮客户生成的东西
这个分布式存储
都是存在我的内存里面
然后要用我的CPU去调用
当Agent的真的需求变大
存储逻辑和CPU逻辑是对应的
而且存储现在增加了贷款
存储贷款
然后增加了数据处理的需求
CPU需要的是
CPU需要的是规格
需要更加新的CPU
所以你会看到的就是
其实现在把存储槽起来
其实CPU大家还没有意识到CPU会缺货
明年就要涨价
明年因为英特尔的芯片要涨价
英特尔芯片要涨三次
我认为是一个比较确定的事情
就是你会看到存储涨价
它已经压了很久没有涨价
你扩产的难度
从右往左难度越来越高
最高是几批
你就扩不了产的外价
然后CPU能够做就两家
其实你能做出来的
就是英特尔和TSMC
TSMC可能是AMD区设计的
但是问题是能够做的就他们这样讲
但存储的三个
它能够扩产
特别是Ned那些就是硬盘
Ned那些其实是commodity商品
它都是可以扩产的
然后光我还是更加容易扩产
但是大家炒的时候肯定是从右炒到左
因为右是马上能够扩产
所以马上能扩产
它马上能出盈利
然后数据就出来好看
然后明年比方说MU现在pricing到6VPE
然后起个头发都是差不多这样的定价
6VPE左右
然后按照明年的产能
产能能够扩产
CPU是需要内存给你用掉
然后插上去以后
CPU开始去货
明年CPU会开始去货
真正预期差最大的时代
CPU就是CPU或者是再加TPU
就是大家现在没有意识到
就是说英伟达的片已经缺到
今年缺300万片
明年缺400万片
所以你不要看库执
它有的全卖掉
就是它一定是按照需求定价
你不能看这个算法上面那个TPU
然后是不是更好
然后我这个是能耗比的事情
我之前讲过就不对数了
但是能耗比的事情就是
现在PW能耗比没有比的上昂老黄
就是英伟达肯定是最好的
肯定是最好的
所以而且OpenAI
你不要去定价它什么出问题
OpenAI的2B的业务做得非常巧
其实谷歌还有点左右互波的意思
就是它原来的业务和新的AI
有点拆
就是在那个
我们在推动业务端是有点左右互波
但是OpenAI在推动业务端非常清晰
就是把2B的业务全部关车下去
然后把2B的东西以后变成它库存
然后做2C
它是8亿越活的2C
然后免费的现在
没有多少Marketing的成本情况下
Train已经Train的金融
它还在Train其他行业
然后把以后你做KYC
客户做KYC
客户做那个认证
客户开户
客户写PPT
包括IPO的perspectives
全部会是一件生产
包括你打完电话会
直接生成一个会议机要的PPT
全部可以给你
已经可以一件生产
那么
这个就是
英伟大
OpenAI
所以你们不要去低估OpenAI的推动
所以这个是我觉得炒的一个逻辑
然后
我快速讲一下
Storage的问题
Storage现在缺货很严重
我告诉你
现在比方说
容耀手机已经没有货了
容耀手机用的是MU的卡了
现在容耀手机在拼命在外面囤货
买货
买不到
所以手机的出货量明年下完之后
所以Storage这个信息
现在还没有市场消化
但是我觉得这里
就这里估值
其实已经基本上市场都知道了
这里估值大部分知道
像我刚刚讲的信息很快都会知道
然后这里缺货还没有到
然后GPU是确定性最高
所以明年会有绑匹
会有的
市场一旦不好
估值杀估值的时候
这些都会被杀
就是你要真的是觉得明年
会有个10%到10%的调整
有可能
光光快到5票
它就能调50%
调50%也很正常
但是它最终可能就长100%
然后存储长100%
但是它真的调起来
也30到50的调
就是真的大家开始质疑的时候
调的都是牛票
长得多的
那现在的仓位不能太低
现在仓位太低的风险
比太高要高
就是现在仓位要偏高
偏高比较说
60到70那种仓位
但是那仓位上
是可以去买
扛打的票
扛打票
比较说什么
我觉得这两个
这两个我一直在讲
你不要说买英伟
你要说英伟达不扛打
它明年的
明年的NIN
因为你
我缺货能缺到400万
那肯定很确定
那明年的NIN就9块5
9块2到9块5
现在就18倍的19vp
你说到扛不扛打
你觉得英伟达跌到15vp
英伟达跌到15vp
这里全部要转
就这里通通要转
这个就是你证伪了
你真的跌到15vp以下
如果说跌到12vp
那你就跌到120块130块钱
那你这个东西就是
把AI的需求给证伪了
AI的需求证伪的情况下
英伟达明年还是有9块2
因为它这个数据中心建完了
就是要把片创进去的
你是这个估值
杀起来会更好
所以确实
你就说到明年
会不会有一个
保安披露
可能是有的
为了应对它
我是说现在空葬
是现在买一些扛打的票
因为在中期
我们是非常看好的
就是明年中期的话
就到明年年底非常看好的
所以我觉得确定性
现在最高的
或者是预期差最大的
英伟达
然后当然了
CPU也是
CPU预期差也蛮大的
你明年
据说AMD要涨
就CPU这个东西
原来是其实大家不涨价
包括出于自身的利益考虑
AMD和GSMG都不想涨价
因为涨价最大的货利是谁
是Intel
Intel就活过来了
就真的活过来了
变成竞争对手了
他的力量很大
大家都知道
所以不太想去涨价
但是就像之前
三星美光和海力士
都在压着Storage
压的是谁
压的是长城和长新
你长城和长新
现在27年
一季度的产能全部拍满
这两个公司
一个400亿一个500英里
就是明年可能到
中国说的那个
你所谓的牛
是吧
炒起来
可能就炒这两个
炒到一万亿
那引力很确定
中国哪有赚500亿的新片公司
这个长城长新
这个生意
如果它不涨价
就全要死
但是他们压的
最终市场
你最后发泄是
做装你压不住的
就Storage的需求
现在大家都知道
后面Storage需求很大
一样的
他们压CPU也压不住的
你CPU的价格涨起来
就是是跟着这个涨的
你要知道
这两个东西是打包的
你在亚马逊上去买云储整储
你就本地你要去部署
自己要去做AI agent
你就知道
存储这个东西
没有CPU你怎么调用
你独显
一定要需要CPU
而且最终明年的
AI的大的方向就是
不管是OpenAI自己做的
还是市场做的
AI agent会出现
而且会兴起
这个就带动了
大量的各种各样的
这些需求
这个我大概就是
比较快
因为这个时间
差不多到
我就大概讲一下
我们对于仓位的配置
然后这个看看
就是我是觉得现在
可以
如果觉得风险
那就配应为了
好吧
看看大家有没有问题
这个是上周的
好吧
要不没什么问题
今天先这样
谢谢大家